the number of americans getting shots
for covid has dipped below
a key benchmark the average number of
vaccinations is now fewer than 1 million
per day
compared to more than 3 million less
than 2 months ago
more than 138 million americans less
than 42 percent of the population are
fully vaccinated
but the large number of unvaccinated
americans is jeopardizing efforts to
achieve
herd immunity it's also an issue for one
texas hospital that requires
its health care workers to get the shots
and now faces a lawsuit from workers who
say they won't
janet chamleon is in houston janet good
morning
anthony good morning houston methodist
is a massive hospital system
eight campuses 26 000 workers for more
than a decade they have been requiring
their workers to get the flu vaccine
but when they mandated the coveted
vaccine more than 100 employees sued
nurse jennifer bridges is the lead
plaintiff in a lawsuit against her
employer of seven years
houston's methodist hospital which is
requiring all workers to get the coveted
vaccine by today
or risk losing their jobs if we're not
comfortable
injecting something into our body do not
fire us and make us lose
our livelihoods hospital ceo dr mark
boom
says 99 of his employees have already
been vaccinated
and calls the lawsuit nonsense we have
incredible real world experience to show
that these are safe and effective
we have a sacred responsibility to keep
our patients safe you have not been
vaccinated
why i am not comfortable yet with it at
all
there's not enough proper research out
yet it's still in the experimental phase
but that argument doesn't hold up to the
science says
cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus
experimental means that you do not know
if it's safe and you don't know if it
works
these are thoroughly tested vaccines
that have been shown to stop the virus
and are very safe while the lawsuit
faces an uphill battle
one part of the complaint could prove
convincing according to cbs news legal
analyst ricky kleeman
their point is that these vaccines
only have been issued for emergency use
only the court could issue an injunction
and really basically say well you can't
fire these employees
yet at least until we know
if the fda is going to grant approval
but it would be a different lawsuit if
the fda gives for approval
but even approval might not convince
everyone
if the vaccine received full fda
approval
would you get vaccinated not anytime
soon
pfizer and modern have already applied
for full fda approval
here at methodist workers who are
unvaccinated by
midnight will be placed on an unpaid
two-week
suspension and then likely lose their
jobs after that time
gail all right janet thank you very much